how's Terell Trace our descent to GTH
greenhand the legendary first king of
the reach who made the land Bloom but so
too does every noble house around us it
seems dear ancestor G planted as many
flowers as he plucked a king should have
more consideration for his line don't
you think for over a thousand years the
greenhand sons and grandsons ruled the
reach as house Gardener the offshoots of
his daughters grew into vast and
Powerful houses in their own right
except for house Terell we chose instead
to serve our gardener cousins Faithfully
as stewards to manage their stronghold
of high garden and the daily Affairs of
the reach our words are growing strong
and under our stewardship the reach did
just that as did we until a blundering
king almost cost us everything for free
you can now listen to the entire audio
book Fire and Blood On which house of
the Dragon is based and which covers the
entire targaryan history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a notable trial
using our Link in the
description Aon Targaryen had landed in
Westeros King M Allied us with the Roth
to repel the upstarts
Army one can only Marvel that King M did
not reconsider when he saw the living
dragons against
him perhaps he should have sought
counsel from his trusted stewards before
he set out then again perhaps he
did at the Field of Fire Aon and let us
not forget his sisters burnt the
combined armies of the reach and rock
King M paid for his misjudgment with his
life and that of his ancient
family in a day the reach had lost its
king its ruling house and most of its
Army thankfully for everyone my ancestor
Harland Terell had better sense until
the maesters sorted out the intale among
Mer's cousins harlon the steward was
acting Lord of high Garden to ensure
peace and life in the reach he would
yield the castle to
Aon the other castles and families would
then follow as they had since the dawn
age aen had a continent to conquer and
the fertile reach was too valuable to ra
he accepted haren's proposal and
welcomed our lands into his kingdom to
show his gratitude aen entitled Haren to
high Garden the castle his family had
served for a thousand years and made
house Terell his wardens of the South
choosing us over older greater families
in the reach our house thus owed
everything to the
targaryens so is it any Wonder we stay
true to King Aries
even during his Madness and even after
Robert Baratheon
rebelled some may question my father for
laying Siege to the barathan home
instead of marching to Aid Prince
rhaegar before Robert could kill him and
Scatter the Royal
Army but let us not forget that we had
already dealt Robert his only defeat of
the war at Ashford if Lord Tywin
Lannister had not vanquished the Mad
King so suddenly our Siege would have
destroyed Robert's home and his brothers
and won the war for
Aries but when the targaryens fell house
Terell again chose peace and prosperity
over war and Devastation and bent the
knee to King Robert barathan first of
his name the Andals swept across
Westeros destroying many ancient
families and kingdoms when the Invaders
arrived at the reach led by Sir Alis
tyell House Gardner chose accommodation
over battle hoping honors and marriages
would sate the Foreigner's Ambitions the
tyrells were welcomed into Service as
hereditary stewards of
hayon thousands of years later they
repaid the gardeners for their
acceptance when Egon tararan declared
that Westeros was now his King M the 9th
allied with King Lauren Lannister of the
westerlands together they fought to save
Westeros from another foreign Barbarian
whose family practices could decent to
shame but the dragons won and the Field
of Fire claimed M and all his sons
grandsons and brothers instead of using
the castle for what it was built to do
Haren Tyrell surrendered it to Egon
without a
fight in exchange Harlem was given the
castle his family had served for
thousands of years with all its
attendant lands and
Lords including my
family some great houses call us
upstarts but the truth is that while the
Starks and Lannisters fell to the
targaryens in defeat house Terell Rose
for thousands of years our family served
as loyal stewards to the kings of the
reach until the last of their line
unwisely burned to death resisting the
tarian
Invaders to save the reach from a
similar fate we yielded the castle of
highgarden to aen and his
sisters in gratitude the targaryens gave
house Terell dominion over the
reach and we became Lords of the castle
in which for Generations we had
served under the targaryan dynasty
Wester us prospered gone were the petty
Wars of Seven Kingdoms and the endless
thirst for minor glories that drove them
the westerlands enriched the realm the
north guarded it and the reach and
riverlands fed it this harmony is what
Robert Baratheon shattered with his
Rebellion against Aries
Targaryen When the Call to Arms came
though we did not want to answer the
reach is a gentle land and honestly the
Mad King was not much loved but we owed
peace and status to his family my father
ma Terell called his banners and marched
North to battle the Rogue storm Lord
Robert who had already defeated three
forces in a single day and at
Ashford my father
won some chasen my father for not
pursuing Robert after the battle we had
cut him off from the stormlands the seat
of his power and he had fled North with
an easy grasp of Lord Tywin Lannister
the hand of Aries for 20 years my father
moved instead to lay Siege to Robert's
ancestral stronghold of Storm's end the
rose would strangle the Stag as the lion
pounced so we
waited but the lion slumbered and Robert
slipped past the king's forces to join
Ned
Stark we could have lifted The Siege and
deployed our armies North to Aid the
crown we could have stormed the walls of
the castle and made Rob
homeless but we had ample supplies
control of land and sea and most of all
patience our Siege would succeed
eventually at little cost of life to
us if Robert prolonged the war with
minor victories our capture of Storm's
end would hasten his
downfall and if Robert won the war well
it would would not do for him to find us
in his halls with the bodies of his
brother Stannis and his sworn men when
the lion finally showed his colors and
purged King's Landing we knew our cause
was
lost my father chose the peaceful route
and bent the knee to Robert who heartily
pardoned
us strange considering how we'd beaten
him and starved his brother to the brink
of
death we were to keep our lands C and
title but we knew that we would never be
welcome at
court it didn't
matter the reach was still the most
fertile of the Seven Kingdoms and under
our
hand every flower even the Rose needs
pruning then it grows
strong the reach is aptly named we're
the ones who give your hands something
to do at the table as the most fertile
region of the Seven Kingdoms we grow the
Lar and share of the grains and fruit
that feed this country especially now
since the rebels have burn down the
other fields yet as with all Gardens
weeds grow in the reach too though few
name them as such singers fill our heads
with chivalry and courtly love fluff to
make boys fight and girls Swoon oh the
songs are good enough for a pleasure
barge down the Manda they give pleasure
to the common people and Harmony to the
realm but if the rise of house Terell
proves anything it's that virtue and
honor have their place and if you're not
careful that place is the grave unlike
the Lannisters Starks and aons we were
never Kings in our own right house
Garder ruled the reach since the dawn
age and we were their stewards while
they Ward to enrich their already rich
domain we manag their castle of high
Garden but then then Aon Targaryen
landed with his dragons nobody knows why
the gardener King took the field against
him anyone could see that a man who
grows flowers should beware a man who
grows fire breathing monsters but maybe
it wasn't holy his idea maybe someone
whispered in his ear about all the face
he'd lose with the other six Kings if he
stayed home the rest is history the last
Gardener King lost his face along with
his body and his Steward Harland Terrell
promptly yielded High Garden to aegon my
grandmother swears that Haren was like
most of our men and grew up banging
steel together too loudly for a thought
to penetrate but luckily his wife had
better sense whatever the case in return
for harland's show of sense aegon
proclaimed house Terell the Lords of the
reach and wardens of the South passing
over all the other houses with better
claims yet Aon chose us centuries later
when his descendant Aries faced
Rebellion the reach stayed loyal mostly
my father mace dealt Robert his only
defeat in the war even if it was my
father's Vanguard who did most of the
fighting before he arrived after the
battle of Ashford we laid Siege to
Storm's end Robert's home unfortunately
the war ended before we could take it
and free up our armies to go save the
king